so yesterday we briefly discussed
comments made by Stacy Abrams where she
proposed a novel solution to our
economic woes as Abrams explained all we
need to do is just kill more children in
case you missed that clip well here it
is again
you're running for governor of Georgia
uh I would assume maybe incorrectly but
while abortion is an issue it nowhere
reaches the level of interest of Voters
in terms of the cost of gas food bread
milk things like that what can a
governor what could you do as governor
to alleviate the concerns of Georgia
voters about those livability daily
hourly issues that they're confronted
with but let's be clear having children
is why you're worried about your price
for gas it's why you're concerned about
how much food costs for women this is
not a reductive issue you can't divorce
being forced to carry an unwanted
pregnancy from the economic realities of
having a child and so these are it's
important for us to have both and
conversations we don't have the luxury
of reducing it or separating them out
but we also have to talk about what a
governor can do a governor can address
housing prices a governor can address
the cost of Education a governor can put
money into the pockets of everyday
hard-working Georgians instead of giving
tax cuts to the wealthy that's what I
talk about on the trail and that's
what's resonating but let's not pretend
that women half the population
especially those of child bearing age
they understand that having a child is
absolutely an economic issue
now I called this a novel solution but
of course that isn't really true there's
nothing novel about it the Democrat
Party has always promoted abortion as a
path to Financial Security and the logic
is simple it's morally depraved but
simple kids cost money
get rid of the kids
get rid of the expense
financial prosperity awaits allegedly
even though it doesn't actually work out
that way this is the eugenic engine that
has driven the pro-abortion movement
since its Inception it's just that only
recently have the pro board started to
once again be more open in their
eugenicism advocacy and I say once again
because years ago
uh before the movement went through a
series of rebrands and they started
talking more about so-called
reproductive health and all the rest of
it before that
um the pro abortion movement used to be
much more direct and explicit about
about all of this and about the fact
that it was advocating for eugenics back
in 1969 the vice president of Planned
Parenthood at the time named Frederick
Jeff
at the request of an organization called
the population Council produced a memo
with a number of recommendations for how
the government could control population
growth this is the jaff memo as it's now
called and it outlines a series of
strategies all falling under four broad
categories and those categories are
social constraints economic deterrence
social controls and preventing unwanted
pregnancy
so just to highlight a few here and we
put the memo up on screen so you can see
it yourself just a few
Jeff suggested restructuring the family
encouraging people to post postpone or
avoid marriage
he coupled this with compulsory
government education and an
encouragement of increased homosexuality
he also recommended that women should
work outside the home under the
deterrent category he listed a number of
strategies including the brilliant idea
that the government could
reduce population by fostering quote
chronic depression
it's actually that's actually on the
memo
elsewhere in the memo he recommends the
Y distribution of contraception along
with sterilization and of course
tax-funded abortion now
some of his ideas like compulsory
abortion for out of wedlock pregnancies
that's one of the things that he
advocated that hasn't yet come to pass
but a great many of them have
in fact all the rest of the ones that I
just listed have
so the eugenesis they told us exactly
what they were going to do and why they
were going to do it
and then they did it and are still doing
it now
it took them several decades but Planned
Parenthood they even found a way to
implement their Mass sterilization plan
under the guise of gender affirmation
they now provide sterilization drugs to
children
so that is yet another box on the jaff
memo which has been checked off
this was the dystopian future that
Planned Parenthood predicted and
advocated for and and fought to
establish
and now we're living in it
actually we're living in something far
beyond it we might say because somewhat
surprisingly Frederick jaff never
thought of or at least didn't include in
his memo
the idea of simply just killing off
large numbers of adults and calling it a
medical treatment
put them down like dogs
euthanasia did not factor into his
calculations not on the memo anyway
perhaps he didn't have an imagination
Twisted enough to conjure up
possibilities like that at the time and
yet at some point
um in the in the Years following the
eugenesis did arrive at this conclusion
and now the death Merchants are rapidly
expanding their war on human life last
week I told you about a report from a
journalist named Rupa subramanya who
reveals the extent of the euthanasia
regime in Canada or the medical
assistance in dying as they call it
there
she Chronicles the plight of one
distraught mother you may recall who's
fighting to prevent her 23 year old son
from killing himself through euthanasia
her son like so many of the other doctor
assisted suicide quote patients in
Canada is not terminally ill terminally
ill he's just he's just depressed
and he know no longer wants to live
rather than provide him with mental and
emotional counseling
his doctors are simply going to kill him
that's their way around it
unless his mother can stop it though she
has no real legal means of doing so
in fact the euthanasia laws are
expanding so much in Canada and are
becoming so permissive
that by early next year they're expected
to start killing miners without parental
consent
although even if they did it with
parental consent that would be no less
horrifying
so Rupert provides more details on just
how pervasive this has become in the
country reading now she says in 2017 the
First full year in which made which is
medical assistance and dying which is
administered by provincial governments
was an operation
2838 people opted for assisted suicide
according to a government report by 2021
that figure had jumped to 10 064
accounting for more than three percent
of all deaths in Canada that year
there have been a total of 31
664 made deaths and the large majority
of those were people uh between the ages
of 65 to 80 when they died in 2017 only
34 made deaths were in the 18 to 45 year
old category in 2018 and that figure
Rose to at least 49.
in 2019 it was 103 in 2020 it was 118
and in 2021 it was 139. today thousands
of people who could live for many years
are applying successfully to kill
themselves indeed in some Canadian
provinces nearly five percent of deaths
are made deaths five percent
in 2021 the province of Quebec reported
that 4.7 percent of deaths in the
province were due to maid in uh British
Columbia the number was 4.8 percent
Progressive Vancouver Island is
officially or rather unofficially known
as the assisted death capital of the
world according to doctors
now the other thing to understand is
that those who apply for doctor-assisted
suicide can have their applications
accepted quickly the process is
streamlined now that what that means is
that you'll have better luck in Canada
getting accepted for euthanasia than you
would for say getting a a building
permit to put an addition on your house
there's usually tons of red tape and it
takes forever to get approval from
anything through the bureaucracy and
that's the case in Canada and the United
States of course
but if you want to kill yourself well
they'll they'll get you through that
process quickly
the AP reported this a few months ago
quote Alan Nichols had a history of
depression and other medical issues but
none were life-threatening when the 61
year old Canadian was hospitalized in
June 2019 over fears he might be
suicidal
he asked his brother to bust him out as
soon as possible
within a month Nichols submitted a
request to be euthanized and and he was
killed within a month
submit the request and was killed within
a month despite concerns raised by his
family and a nurse practitioner his
application for euthanasia listed only
one health condition as the reason for
his request to die hearing loss
nichols's family reported the case to
police and health authorities arguing
that he lacked the capacity to
understand the process and was not
suffering unbearably among the
requirements for euthanasia they say he
was not taking needed medication wasn't
using the implant that helped him hear
that hospital staff staffers improperly
helped him request euthanasia
now think about that for a second he was
sent to the doctor
he was sent to the hospital because he
was suicidal
and his family thought the hospital
would help save him from suicide and
instead according to the family
the staff at the hospital
helped him kill himself
they killed this man because he had
hearing loss
they'll also kill you in Canada if
you're homeless city news has a report
about a 54 year old name man named Amir
farsood in Ontario he applied for
medical assistance in dying and has
already received one of the two doctor's
letters of approval that he needs all
because he is potentially about to be
homeless
here's their report
how would you describe the quality of
your life
um
awful non-existent terrible I do nothing
other than sort of manage symptoms
manage pain
there we go Amir farsood lives with
never-ending Agony from a back injury
how bad does it get
um
at worst that gets bad enough that I'm
crying like a five-year-old and not
sleeping for two days in a row
but that's not why he has applied for
medically assisted dying otherwise known
as made nor is it the depression he
lives with farsood has applied because
he is in danger of losing his housing he
lives in this Saint Catherine's rooming
house sharing this space with two other
people but it is up for sale farsood
lives on social assistance and says he
can't find anywhere else he can afford
I don't want to die but I don't want to
be homeless more than I don't want to
die medically assisted dying in Canada
was expanded this past march to include
people with disabilities or those
suffering in pain even if they are not
close to death
now the thing to remember about this is
that uh it is not as though all of these
people would have killed themselves
anyway
and all Canada is doing is providing
them a
painless way of killing themselves
now if that were the case it would still
be horrifying it would still be a
horrifying reality
but it's not the case
you know there's it more people are
killing us people who would not have
otherwise people who would have who
would have uh who would have fought on
and continued living and found a way to
keep keep living and to deal with their
their problems someone like this for
example
I mean homelessness is a very real
problem and if you're going through that
or being threatened with something like
that or or you're worried about the
possibility of that it's a it is to call
it distressing of course would be an
understatement
but you can live through it you can
fight through it there's there's still
hope there's light at the end of the
tunnel
and a great many of these people they
would if they didn't have this system in
place to just Usher them off the planet
Usher them out of their own lives if
that system wasn't in place many of
these people would continue living
so I think Stacy Abrams when she sees
that she'd be proud
because rather than make the country our
country more livable for children Abrams
Abrams suggests that we simply kill them
and in Canada rather than address the
homelessness problem
they'll just start Exterminating them
rather than address the problem of
depression and despair and mental
illness
Just Kill Them All
they're not going to concern themselves
with coming up with policies or
strategies that may help human beings be
happy and flourish
No in fact it's the opposite because
human flourishing
is a negative in their minds
according to the powers that be
according to the leftists
human flourishing is a negative it's the
opposite of what they desire
human flourishing as the jaff memo
showed in 1969 is the problem that they
seek to solve
and they have spent decades solving it
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block portion hope to see you there if
not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]